hey you get your [ __ ] hands off me
your jimmy stewart is just well it just
isn't what it used to be you know
it's slipping away now would you stand
up for a minute jim
let me give you let me give you a few
pointers here now
now the first thing you got to do is put
your hand out like like this and just
kind of shake it like that that's that's
good that's good that's good
now i want you to kind of look through
the tops of your eyes and give it that
okay no no kind of squint them a little
bit and bend over just about there
now i want you to say i feel terrible
here's the thing there's no way he's my
son
yeah here's the thing mom let me explain
first of all
uh this is not my dad it's a waste of my
damn time it's what it is
okay this man wasn't my dad back then he
ain't my dad now
steven b smith what do you think yeah
well let me just say bye start by
clarifying as far as mark greenberg goes
i mean no ill will no animosity or
acrimonious hostility toward him as i
progress with my favorable insight
any characterization of michael lewis
golick or simply as one half of the team
of the mike's listening extravaganza
that is mike and mike now i know mike
greenberg
and he is a friend and when i say he's a
friend i mean that i'm sitting in the
same
city vicinity as him as at this current
juncture but i digress
this dissertative verbal essay is
supposed to be about positive
attributes qualities characteristics of
my goal of the quintessential every man
a man who accorded to the dan levitad
program right here on espn radio
is like the guy on a construction site
with plumber's crack working on a sewage
pipe
and yelling i need some lack down here
he's you eating me
well he's not me there's nobody who's me
stay tuned for more of the sammy davis
junior tribute
honoring the one heavyweight i would
never dare step into the ring with
sammy you're a true undefeated champ
oh wait
i think mike can do a little better than
that mike
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna attempt to read
this this may be disastrous
okay stay tuned for more of the sammy
davis jr trivia
honoring the one heavyweight i would
never dare step into the ring with
sammy you are truly the undefeated
champion
[Applause]
the producers of the show the producers
of the show was hoping you'd have a
little more
feeling more mike you know a little bit
more mike tyson
you know more mike tysonism like like
hello ladies and gentlemen sammy and i
like it's like going into your closet
except there's a guy in there
hey buddy pocket t really thanks cap
what you refolded this place is great
[Applause]
isn't this brave
[Applause]
another day another
fifty thousand dollars
no jack said uh the one thing about
nichols is he's a comic the bastard's
always laughing it's like working with a
damn clown in a director's chair
but i've been doing shaq for so long i
can tell you exactly what he's thinking
right now
all my friends are saying mean things
hurt my feelings shack a big strong man
outside
what's off inside shaq hate bullets
everyone is calling shaq dumb but shaq
not dumb
i have a doctorate charles is a dumb one
charles probably think dr redd is a girl
doctor
shaka boy doctor
[Applause]
ah
i know i know you love me tonight but
will you respect me in the morning
hey how how about this how about this
weather where
we're having out here in california in
the wild
i love that tape
and i show it to all my friends
well maybe we'll just turn the camera on
and let him go
i improvised for about two hours after
that
then with clem's help we uh we honed the
final performance down to
this little piece that i'd like to
perform for you now
hey man i can handle it
this nick is calm and stealthy like a
ninja warrior
whereas this nick is an exaggerated
screaming
psychopath and it really just
doesn't exist
that's high praise
[Music]
we see that look that chuck has given me
over there that i hope
it doesn't break into my voice that's
going to bend us he does not sound like
me
it looks like a fool can i tell him he's
crazy i'm just waiting number one
i from the from the clip that was you
talking my phone
i let me mirror what you're doing over
there
all right that's how bad stuff happened
around here
you know it's been really fun watching
all your promos
but i'm not going to be happy they say
you do me really well
he's
i'm listening right now but i don't hear
what it's going with it just doesn't
sound
it doesn't sound right that guy's a
knucklehead i don't know what he's
thinking
you know what he said let me tell you
something hold on a second i never get
to finish
anything here i start to say something
everybody takes it away from me
how come i can't finish a sentence in
this place what's what's the problem
here
that's not bad no hold on a second
where's my camera take a look stop if
you're going to switch cameras let me
know okay don't make me look like an
idiot over here all right
[Music]
kevin how are you nice to see you oh
shut up dave
they like it i like it i worked on
something
just for this moment
okay i had to write it down
okay
[Applause]
here it is
[Applause]
oh thank you but i get a cappuccino
oh dave you're a big man yeah
i'll give you a stick of gum you can
show me how to chew it
me me do me oh let me ask you this
question
house house your brother uh
which one do you mean george they are
the the one with the uh with the
the appendicitis scar up up there and
now appendicitis is on the stomach
i know but it was so ticklish
play so i press play and it plays go
backwards
i press rewind it actually goes back in
time take a look at this guys man
take a look at what's going on here
we're actually breaking the space-time
continuum man
who designed the forward backward
mechanism that goes on with this thing